it was an occasion that was all full a
slight curiosity is some elements that
were almost unique and hovering over it
of course was that fact that the
circumstance of this was a former Pope
having died and this ceremony being
conducted by the present Pope
fabrication
did it to be rather an uplifting joyful
occasion despite the fact that it was
marking a death why would that be well
Pope Benedict uh hope Emeritus was an
old man we knew that his life was coming
to an end and I think for many here they
saw this as him moving uh out of this
world and off towards uh towards the
next uh they also felt that he had
contributed so much to the uh to the
Catholic faith as a scholar and then as
Pope and I think uniformly the people
I've spoken to here have considered to
it to have been a courageous decision a
word we've heard again and again
of him to retire from the position as
Pope when he felt that it is mental and
physical acuities were no longer fit for
the role so there was a lot of warmth
here now of course this is in a sense a
self-selecting audience for people who
come here to Saint Peters to mourn
Benedict were of course those who
supported him as well as as the vast uh
ranks of monks and Bishops and of course
the Cardinals who were here as well but
I think this is a point of inflection
for the Catholic Church
which and remember there are 1.4 billion
Catholics around this world who were
watching on as today unfolded
I think it is a day that that brings up
a couple of of important questions one
is whether or not Pope Francis will now
feel that he can lead the Catholic
church in a different way well why well
perhaps because Benedict are more
conservative Pope may have become a
lightning rod for some of that
conservative opinion uh Pope Benedict is
no longer with us so could it be that
Pope Francis brings in a more liberal
agenda that has been suggested by some
others say that they don't see evidence
that Pope Francis has ever been
inhibited the second thing is whether or
not Francis a man who lives with ill
health now may consider that there is a
space if you like for a former pope now
in the world and that he may consider
bringing his own papacy to an end in the
coming months or or perhaps years well
around us you may be able to hear they
are packing up this event such a focus
this morning is now being dismantled a
sign I think that even here at the heart
of the Catholic Church the waves do come
along and uh and wipe away the marks on
the beach life returns to normal
relatively quickly but what will be the
ripples of those waves how they will
change the church in the weeks months
and years to come because that still the
weights to be discovered